hi there this is Jake from Geek culture
and as you can see from everything on
this table we're very excited to be
unboxing the new PlayStation 5 consoles
not PlayStation 5 Slims but redesigned
just a little bit Slimmer so let's get
right to it so here we have the new
PlayStation 5 consoles that have been
redesigned uh to have a smaller
footprint compared to their bigger
larger
predecessors uh it's not exactly a
upgrade in a sense there's no
performance upgrade like the PlayStation
4 and the PlayStation 4
Pro oh it's
glossy have you seen the gloss on
this so when you buy new console covers
it's going to come in four pieces
instead of two uh like we used
to I know maybe some people like
different colors for their top and
bottom plates which is fine so as you
can see both PlayStation 5's uh this and
this lless version they don't come with
that vertical horizontal stand thing
that came with the original PS5 in their
place we have these plastic packs it's
supposed to hold up your console while
lying horizontally they have this
separate vertical standand that'll be
selling and there you have it the
redesigned PlayStation 5 both the disc
and The discus version these two
consoles are standing at the same height
and because we want to compare it to the
original PlayStation 5S but our
companies PlayStation 5 consoles are off
in a secret location because they're
reviewing something secret as well we
can only compare it with this closest
thing that we have in the office what's
up everyone it's Zeno and yeah so we
didn't have the PlayStation 5s on hand
when we were shooting this video but we
do now so let me just run through that
with you right so here is The Standard
Version this is the newer PS5 and over
here we have the OG PS5 so Sony has said
that these PSI are about 30% smaller and
you can definitely see that here there
is this much space left over here that's
that's quite a bit because they shaved
off this much height you got a nice and
compact PS5 right here it's the same
thing with the digital about 30% has
been Shed off the OG PS5 digital version
over here and yeah if space is a luxury
in your home these pfv would do the
trick before we get into it this channel
is supported by Brands who help us
improve our content and keep us going so
stay around for this sponsored message
here at geek culture we've tested plenty
of chairs but Secret Life gaming chairs
remain one of our favorites whether it's
for work or play they feel great to lean
back against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head and back to the arms and even
something for your butt this mix of
fourman function helps the Titan Evo
2022 to deliver the best seating
experience like no other for more
information check out secretlab.co now
let's get right to putting these babies
horizontally then so you can see this is
where the packs will go there two holes
here and then two holes here so let's
put them right in so you can see how it
works in
action and there we go taada and there
you go your PlayStation 5 disc version
is now stable with the help of those
plastic Pags that's for the packs for
the digital version they are a little
bit smaller compared to the disc version
and there you go both versions of the
new PlayStation 5 all lying down
horizontally and made stable with the
help of those plastic packs however if
you're like me who prefer to have your
console standing up vertically you're
going to have to purchase a separate
vertical
stand which will work for both this and
this lless version of the new PS5 they
even have an additional plate which you
can use if you have one of the older
generation PlayStation vies so let's see
how easy it is to install it you're
going to remove this little covering
over here and then you're going to place
your vertical stand here this circle
with uh the triangle and circle symbols
you going to cover up here you're going
to take that included screw just put it
in here the other hole and just screw it
in tightly with your hands once we're
done you have it your new console
standing up vertically with a nice
metallic circular vertical stand and
there you have it your brand new
PlayStation 5 standing vertically with
the help of a circular metallic stand
that looks honestly quite premium so for
those of you who bought the dless
PlayStation 5 but suddenly developed the
hankering to play physical media namely
Blu-ray disc Sony has a solution for you
with the additional disc drive always
remember to keep these plastic feet cuz
they're needed you know if you ever want
to take the disc drive out again
we're going to remove the cover I think
so if I'm not wrong we're going to
remove this
somehow oh God I better read again oh
scary
sounds oh strong plastic yeah so with
the cover removed you're going to take
your disc drive you take a look at uh
the bottom of it you're going to see
this connector right here is going to go
into this hole right here and then you
can to take these protrusions line it up
with the grooves found here
insert that in drop it in and if all
things line up perfectly your disc drive
will be safely in place now take the
cover same thing I'm afraid of breaking
plastic
but I think that's it that's it taada
transformed your dless version of your
PlayStation 5 is now a dis version just
like this one they look almost identical
since there is no performance
differences between the two ps5s neither
is there any performance differences
between the new generation of PS5 versus
the older Generations but the bonus is
you get all one tab of storage compared
to the previous one who only had 825
gigs of storage and we're done so if you
have any questions regarding the new
generation of PlayStation 5 consoles be
sure to leave them in the comments below
and we'll get right back to you to keep
out with the latest and greatest of all
things that geek culture cares about be
sure to check out all our socials and do
like and subscribe cuz it goes a long
way this is Jake signing off from Geek
culture I'll see you at the next
[Music]
one